guten abend
der sie was ist das heute ein bitterer
tag für sie oder für die afd
ach so würde ich da gar nicht rangehen
das ist für mich ein tag eines abschieds
der tut auch weh da will ich keinen hehl
draus machen das war ein achteinhalb
jahre arbeit es ist für mich aber
zugleich auch ein neuer anfang es ist
beides der rechtsextreme flügel ist
aufgelöst hieß es immer aus der afd das
war dann ja wohl immer ein formales
feigenblatt tatsächlich sehen wir heute
hat der flügel gewonnen blöcke wünscht
ihnen für ihren weiteren lebensweg mehr
zufriedenheit
sehr freundlich von haacke ja aber das
heißt doch dass die ganze zeit dieser
flügel der den auch sie immer als
aufgelöst bezeichnet hatten in
wirklichkeit die fäden zieht in der kfd
der flügel der begann institutionelle
strukturen zu entwickeln dagegen haben
wir uns gewendet und dann haben wir
aufgelöst und das geschah auch das heißt
natürlich nicht dass die menschen die
sich dieser gruppierung zugehörig
fühlten auf einmal weg sind die waren
weiterhin da und parteimitglieder und
die arbeiten weiter und ich habe immer
gesagt wir haben in dieser partei im
kern zwei strömungen
eine bürgerlich konservativ
freiheitliche und eine eher national
konservativ in teilen völkische das war
immer der grundkonflikt in dieser partei
und er ist bis zum heutigen tage aber
mit dem heutigen tage zieht sich die
eine strömung in ihrer person nämlich
zurück und sie sagen heute
totalitäre anklänge habe ihre ex partei
sollte heute etwas sektenhafte machen
sie daraus das sehen ja andere
beobachter schon viel länger so als sie
was konkret hat sie denn jetzt zu diesem
schritt bewogen oder vielleicht anders
gefragt wer hat sie dazu bewogen
es waren keine konkreten personen es ist
eine kette von ereignissen die dann
langsam dahin geführt hat dass ich zu
der erkenntnis gelangt bin dass der weg
von maß und mitte der weg von
disziplinierung und professionalisierung
wenig immer angemahnt habe und ich habe
das sehr sehr entschieden getan
ich erinnere an den parteitag in kalkar
der fast tumultartige dann verlief
aufgrund meiner brandrede dass dieser
weg tatsächlich nicht von erfolg gekrönt
sein wird und dass ich mich mit den
vorstellungen welchen weg die parteien
nehmen müsse nicht durchsetzen wort aber
ich muss da noch mal nachfragen weil
woran konkret machen sie das denn jetzt
alles fest sie sagen ich kenne den laden
von innen das ist ein zitat von ihnen
von heute was können sie denn den
deutschen jetzt heute abend über diese
partei sagen was sie als parteichef
nicht konnten oder nicht sagen wollten
also ich verstehe ihr interesse dass ich
da jetzt ganz viele geschichten erzählt
ich möchte nur nicht unfair sein und
nach treten wissen sie das vermeintliche
sollen nicht ganz viele geschichten
erzählen sondern wir versuchen einfach
herauszufinden was sie zu diesem doch
sehr sehr krassen schritt bewogen hat
heute ich gebe ihnen ein beispiel
ich habe im bundesvorstand im august
letzten jahres massiv dafür geworben ein
parteiausschlussverfahren gegen ein
mitglied durchzuführen
das sich als das freundliche gesicht des
nationalsozialismus bezeichnet ich sage
dass da werden grenzen überschritten
diesen völlig undenkbar auch wenn das
vielleicht in einer internen
kommunikation gelaufen ist dahinter
steckt ja eine geisteshaltung und ich
habe dort und das ist seitdem mehrfach
passiert festgestellt dass die
mehrheitlich im bundesvorstand hatte mir
nicht gefolgt ist ich habe mich zu
teilen gefühlt wie ein feldherr dessen
soldaten sich in die büsche schlagen
weil auch andere überlegungen für die
eine rolle spielen und wenn man sich
dann mehrfach nicht durchsetzen kann und
das ist mir so geschehen und es ließen
sich weitere beispiele nennen dann fragt
man sich ob man mit dem kurs für den man
mit herzblut steht ob man mit diesem
kurs noch erfolgreich sein kann und habe
gemerkt ich bin es nicht und ich habe
gesehen dass ich den weg ab einem
bestimmten punkt nicht mehr mitgehen
kann ich bin sehr beharrlich im
verfolgen meiner ziele und ich werfe die
flinte nicht gleich ins korn sondern ich
versuche so lange es irgend möglich ist
und ich sage es ist ein punkt gekommen
an dem es nicht möglich ist und daraus
sich die konsequenz und drehte von
meinen ämtern zurück und aus der partei
aus weil sie einen weg nimmt den ich
nicht zu gehen bereit gehen dh in der
afg nach ihm würden sie das so sagen
kann man sich jetzt als freundliches
gesicht des nationalsozialismus
bezeichnen darüber müssen die befinden
die da sind ich bin nicht mehr da ich
habe dazu eine klare position gehabt wie
zu anderen dingen auch
es hat keine mehrheit dafür im
bundesvorstand gegeben dann ging es an
leine landesschiedsgericht
in diesem landesschiedsgericht die
saison gerne ämter sperre braucht man
vielleicht auch nicht eine abmahnung tut
das und das ist genau die
verweichlichung von positionen die ich
nicht mitzugehen was sagt denn dass über
ihre partei bis heute ihre partei
das heißt dass eine abgrenzung die mir
zwingend notwendig erscheint nicht in
der notwendigen härte und schärfe
vorgenommen wird der verfassungsschutz
will die afg beobachten wegen
rechtsextremistischer bestrebungen sie
sind ja jetzt quasi der beste kronzeuge
dafür oder also ich fühle ich mich nicht
ich bin auch kein innenpolitiker ich bin
kein jurist ich nehme politische
wertungen vor und meine politische
wertung ist dass die partei einen kurs
mit dem ich nicht einverstanden bin und
den ich auch nicht mitzugehen bereit
wenn ich will eine konservative politik
eine reaktionäre ich will eine
freiheitliche keine beliebige ich will
eine patriotische aber keine
nationalistische politik das sind die
positionen die ich habe und es geht
eindeutig in die andere richtung und
daraus ziehe ich die für mich logische
konsequenz dass man ihn in partei nicht
mehr sein kann muss jeder einzelne für
sich selbst entscheiden sie haben jetzt
mehrfach gesagt das sind ihre positionen
aber wenn man mal ein bisschen zurück
kommt und so weit muss man da gar nicht
zurück gucken wollten das ist von
erstaunlicher sinneswandel den sie da
letztlich durchgemacht haben sie haben
noch 2020 in interviews gesagt die
haltungen des rechtsextremen flügels die
seien legitim sie haben davor gesagt der
flügel ist selbstverständlich ein
integraler bestandteil der partei also
man muss sagen wenn es ihnen taktisch
half da haben sie da durchaus paktiert
muss man mit dem heutigen tag eigentlich
sagen sie basteln im grunde genommen
einfach nur an einer legende für ihre
person nein das ist das ist eine
erzählung die sehr gerne bemüht wird
dieser aber nicht stimmt sondern ich
habe mich immer da wo es erkannt habe
gegensteuern gegen entwicklungen gewandt
die ich für indiskutabel das habe ich
schon im jahr 2016 gemacht als ich
gesagt habe ich setze mich nicht mit
einem antisemiten in eine fraktion und
die ich habe alles dafür getan dass
dieser mensch dann nicht in der partei
bleibt das ist im deutschen parteien
recht nicht einfach das hat vier jahre
gebraucht gerade auch zutaten vor 2020
vorgelesen wo sie sagten die haltungen
des flügels sind legitim
ich bin auch durchaus der meinung dass
man in einer freiheitlichen demokratien
breites meinungsspektrum tolerieren muss
deswegen muss ich mir diese meinung
nicht zu eigen machen das habe ich nie
gemacht auch als ich noch davor mal auf
treffen von denen war habe ich immer
gesagt das sind positionen die nicht
meine eigenen sind ich habe in einem
punkt geht und das gestehe ich frank und
frei ein ich habe das für weit weniger
dominant gehalten ich habe gedacht wir
machen einen integrativen kurs und wir
versuchen es zusammen zu führen zu einer
gesamten konservativen partei man kann
nicht hingehen und kann sagen ich
akzeptiere nur meine position ich habe
nie einen hehl daraus gemacht dass die
positionen die etwa 1 gehören höcke
vertritt ganz und gar nicht meine
positionen sind aber wenn man zu einer
größeren partei werden will dann
versucht man zu integrieren diese
integrationskurs ist gescheitert weil
die versucht haben und das nicht ganz
erfolglos
nicht der flügel zu sein sondern wie man
jemand ganz gross gesagt hat der ganze
vogel das geht nicht am morgen ganz kurz
noch wo sehen sie die afg in den
kommenden monaten ich
habe mir zwei fragen gestellt vor dieser
entscheidung die eine ist wie wird der
weg dieser partei sein in zukunft der
andere kann ich das mit gehen und sie
fragen jetzt nach der ersten frage ich
glaube dass die afg eine entwicklung
nimmt die keinen weiteren politischen
erfolg in diesem land verheißt weil sie
sich einfach in eine richtung bewegt die
diesen erfolg nicht hergibt und ich muss
ihnen sagen aufgrund meiner eigenen
position das halte ich dann auch für
richtig halten bis heute herzlichen dank
für das gespräch ich danke ihnen in
sivas